Herzlich willkommen. Heute ist der 10. Jahr für Sie und ich werde das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Erstmal benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten von Ihnen und dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden.
Was Sie Fragen haben, vergehen Sie bitte nicht mich zu unterbrechen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Mario Leber.
Ich buchstabiere mal eben L E B E R. Richtig oder?
Ja wie Herz, Leber, Milz, Leber.
Ihre Vorname? M A R I O.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Wie alt sind Sie Herr Leber?
Ich bin 62.
Ihr Geburtstatum bitte.
Ja, 8. März 1963 bin ich am Geburtstab.
Sind Sie wie groß?
Ich bin 1,77 Meter.
Ihr Gewicht bitte.
98 Kilogramm wiege ich.
Haben Sie einen Hausarzt oder eine Hausärztin, Herr Leber?
Ja, ich habe einen Hausarzt, der heißt Wolfgang Stein.
Ein Doppelname oder?
Nein, Wolfgang, Vorname Stein, Nachname.
Herr Stein.
Was führt Sie heute zu uns, Herr Leber?
Herr Doktor, normalerweise komme ich hier nicht, möchte ich nicht kommen, aber mein Freund hat mir besonders empfohlen, zu Ihnen zu besuchen.
Seit zwei Monaten habe ich ein Geschwür.
Das tut nicht weh, für mich ist es nicht wichtig, aber mein Freund hat mir besonders gesagt, zu besuchen.
In der Unterlippe habe ich ein Geschwür.
Seit zwei oder drei Monaten?
Seit zwei Monaten.
Blut ist manchmal?
Ja, manchmal, wenn ich schlafe, manchmal schlafe ich und wenn ich schlafe, blutet es.
Wenn ich saure esse, zum Beispiel Zitrone, habe ich ein brennendes Gefühl in der Lippe.
Es tut nicht weh, normalerweise.
Aber besonders stört es mir, Kosmetikprobleme habe ich.
Deswegen?
Wenn Sie saures essen, gegessen haben, spüren Sie es nicht, oder?
Ja, ja, ja, normalerweise spüren wir es.
Aber wenn Sie keine essen?
Ja, ja, ja.
Gibt es irgendwelche Auslöser dafür, für die Geschwür?
Ich weiß nicht, es war normalerweise klein.
Haben Sie gebissen?
Ja, ich erinnere mich nicht, aber vielleicht.
Ich erinnere mich, aber es war zuerst klein und dünn, aber im Verlauf der Zeit, es sich vergrößert.
Und es wurde ein bisschen dick.
Welche Farbe hat es?
Das ist wie braun, dunkelrot, das ist gemischt, mehrfarbig, ich kann sagen.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, Herr Leber?
Haben Sie Geschwürlen, haben Sie Vergrößerung oder Knoten im Hals?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt, aber ich huste regelmäßig.
Seit besonders zwei Jahren habe ich husten und gelblich und schleimig Auswurf auch habe ich.
Haben Sie bestimmte Lungenerkrankungen?
Bestimmte Lungenerkrankungen hatte ich normalerweise nicht, aber ich huste manchmal.
Das ist normal, denke ich. Ich rauche sehr viel, zu viel.
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Seit 40 Jahren, Herr Doktor.
Wie viele Zigaretten rauchen Sie täglich?
Seit 20 Jahren habe ich meinen Zigarettenkonsum reduziert.
Seit 20 Jahren rauche ich eine Schachtel.
Bevor habe ich zwei Schachteln geraucht, 20 Jahre lang.
Haben Sie Zahnfleischprobleme oder Zähneprobleme?
Meine Zähne sind nicht sauber, Herr Doktor. Ich kümmere mich um nichts.
Ich bin leidlich und alleine. Deswegen weiß ich nicht.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Dyspnoe?
Ja, nicht so. Wenn ich sehr hoch treffe steige, habe ich manchmal Atemnot, aber nicht sehr schwer.
Aber seit einem Monat fühle ich mich fieberig, aber ich habe nicht gemessen.
Haben Sie Schüttelfrost?
Schüttelfrost habe ich nicht, aber manche Nacht schwitze ich, als ich geduscht habe.
Wie geduscht habe?
Ja, wie ich geduscht habe.
Seit wann haben Sie das?
Seit einem Monat.
Waren Sie deswegen, ich meine wegen des Geschwürs beim Arzt?
Nein, erstmals.
Haben Sie gegen irgendwelche Medikamente genommen?
Nein, nein, ich habe nicht.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, aber obwohl ich sehr gut esse, habe ich 12 Kilo abgenommen im letzten Jahr.
In einem Jahr?
In einem Jahr mehr.
Aber haben Sie keine Inappetit oder wenig Appetit?
Nein, ich esse alles, denke ich. Aber ich habe abgenommen.
Würden Sie sich übergeben, Herr Leber?
Nein, ich habe keine Übelkeit oder habe ich nicht erbrochen.
Wie ist das mit Schüturgang und Wasserlassen?
Ja, das ist ganz normal, aber ich leide unter Verstöpfung seit mehreren Jahren.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ja, ich esse Fisch.
Sie essen Obst?
Ja, Obst und Saft trinke ich.
Hat es Ihnen geholfen?
Manchmal habe ich geholfen, manchmal nicht.
Haben Sie Schlafstörungen, Herr Leber?
Können Sie gut schlafen?
Seit einem Monat habe ich Schlafstörungen. Ich kann nicht einschlafen.
Wegen Nachschweiß oder?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich muss 1 oder 2 Stunden versuchen, zu schlafen.
Haben Sie Einschlafstörungen?
Ja.
Haben Sie Stress im Leben?
Ja, ich bin alleine, deswegen habe ich Stress.
Haben Sie Schluckbeschwerden, Herr Leber?
Schluckbeschwerden habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Ist Ihnen Heißigkeit aufgefallen?
Ja, manchmal wenn ich Grippe habe, habe ich Heißarbeit, aber jetzt nicht.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich leide seit 20 Jahren an der Zuckerkrankheit.
Ich spritze 6 Einheiten Insulin morgens.
Einmal täglich, oder?
Ja, und ich nehme Metformin zweimal täglich.
Wann spritzen Sie? Am Morgen oder abends? Ich glaube abends.
Ja, abends spritze ich.
Und Metformin, in welcher Dosis?
1.000 Milligramm.
1.000?
Zweimal.
Morgens und abends, oder?
Ja.
Haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ja, viel Herr Doktor, viel.
Was haben Sie noch erlebt?
Brutaltruppe, ich habe viel Herzerkrankungen, ich habe zweimal Herzinfarkt gehabt.
Deswegen habe ich zwei Ständen bekommen.
Zweimal.
Wurde bei Ihnen ein Angio?
Ja, zweimal.
Wurde ein Angio eingeführt, an Geografien.
Wegen an Herzinfarkt, wegen des Herzinfarkts.
Ja, ja.
Am 2004 und 2015 habe ich zweimal Herzinfarkt bekommen.
Das habe ich zu hören erlebt. Seit wann haben Sie Brutaltruppe?
Seit über 10 Jahren.
Was meinen Sie damit? 15 oder 17?
Vielleicht zwölf Jahre.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ramiplil nehme ich.
In welcher Dose ist das?
Ich erinnere mich nicht, Herr Doktor, nicht.
Mein Medikament ist zu Hause.
Ich kann Ihren Hausarzt nachfragen. Machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen.
Was nehmen Sie gegen Herzprobleme, gegen Herzkrankungen?
Sie haben zwei Ständen bekommen.
Ich nehme regelmäßig Choraspin.
100 mg oder?
Ja, ja. Und Beloxog.
Beloxog.
In welcher Dose wissen Sie das?
50 mg.
50?
Ja, 50 mg täglich.
Suchen Sie Ihren Kardiologen regelmäßig?
Ja, ich habe vor sechs Monaten besucht.
Außer Angio wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich habe keine andere Operation gehabt.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten, Herr Leber?
Ich habe keine Allergien, aber ich kann nicht Milchprodukte essen.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Bauchschmerzen.
Trinken Sie Alkohol, Herr Leber?
Ja, ich trinke jeden Abend ein kleines Glas Seft.
Gut zu schlafen.
Was meinen Sie, ein kleines Glas? Ein halbes Glas oder?
Vielleicht ein halbes Glas.
Seft?
Ja.
Seit wann trinken Sie?
Seit Jahren, vielleicht 30 Jahren.
30 Jahre.
Nehmen Sie die folgenden Fragen nicht persönlich.
Aus medizinischen Gründen fragen wir immer.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Jetzt nehme ich nicht oder frage ich nicht.
Ich freue mich, Herr Leber.
Sie sind ledig und leben allein.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Was sind Sie für einen Beruf?
Ich bin Rentner.
Früher war ich Rentner.
Wegen Erkrankungen.
Vor fünf Jahren bin ich Rentner gegangen.
Ich war Büroangestellter.
Büroangestellter.
Gibt es chronische Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Ihr Vater, Ihre Mutter?
Mein Vater ist vor zwei Jahren an Herzinfarkten gestorben.
Mein sehr beiliebt.
Herr Leber.
Aber meine Mutter ist ganz gesund, Herr Doktor.
Gut zu hören.
Wie ein deutscher Motor.
Haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Wie?
Ja, ich habe auch einen Bruder.
Ich hatte einen Bruder.
Er ist vor zehn Jahren an Herzinfarkten gestorben.
Ein sehr beiliebt Bruder.
Könnten Sie es wiederholen?
Wie bitte Herr Leber?
Ja, kann ich auch einen Herzinfarkten haben, Herr Doktor?
Ich wüsste auch.
Warum denken Sie an Schlimmsten, Herr Leber?
Bitte nicht.
Mein Bruder ist vor 40 Jahren gestorben.
Ich bin sehr beiliebt, Herr Leber.
Es ist zu früh etwas Genaues zu sagen.
Das ist ein Amnesgespräch.
Danach werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Und eine Labor- und Apparativ-Untersuchung.
Dann können wir entscheiden, Herr Leber.
Herr Doktor, ich habe Angst natürlich.
Machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen, bitte.
Wir tun alles für Sie.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, Herr Doktor.
Es war sehr früh.
Ich habe keine Impfung-Mappe dabei.
Gegen Covid-19 zum Beispiel?
Ja, ich hatte Covid-Impfung.
Kinderkrankheit?
Als Sie Kind waren, bekamen Sie Spritzen?
Ja, denke ich schon.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob genau.
Das war alles, Herr Leber.
Besuchen Sie Ihr Haus regelmäßig?
Ja, ich besuche vielmals pro Jahr.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, nein, nein.
Haben Sie noch weitere Beschwerden, Herr Leber?
Ja, das sieht sehr schlecht aus.
Meine Lippe sieht sehr schlecht aus.
Können Sie das entnehmen, oder?
Es ist zu früh etwas Genaues zu sagen, Herr Leber.
Gibt es eine Salbe für meinen Geschwür?
Ja, jetzt werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschüren.
Und gegebenenfalls werde ich eine Gewebeprobe entnehmen.
Warum eine körperliche Untersuchung?
Ich habe nur einen Geschwür in der Lippe.
Sie klagen über Husten und Gewichtverlust.
Wir sollten eine Untersuchung durchschüren.
Okay, Sie sind Arzt, Herr Doktor.
Ich entscheide das.
Okay, Herr Doktor.
Ich vertraue Ihnen.
Ja, bitte machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorge.
Wir sind für Sie da.
Muss ich im Krankenhaus bleiben, oder kann ich nach Hause gehen?
Nun werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschüren.
Okay, Herr Doktor.
Einverstanden. Vielen Dank.
Gern. Guten Tag.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen,
den ich eben in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Hätten Sie kurz Zeit?
Ja, bitte schön.
Es handelt sich um Mario Leber,
ein 62-jähriger Patient, geboren am 08.03.1963,
1,77 Meter groß, 98 Kilogramm schwer.
Er stellte sich bei uns vor auf Grund seit zwei Monaten bestehenden,
zunehmenden, allmählich aufgetretenen Geschwür oder Ulkus
in der untenen Lippen.
Er klagte über alle Aspekteleit-Symptomen,
liegen Pyruritus vor.
Er beschrieb das Geschwür,
das Geschwür habe braun und dunkelfarbige,
und wenn er saures Lebensmittel gegessen hat,
blutet das Geschwür.
Die Frage nach Halsödema oder Knoten,
Takikadi, Dyspnoe, Heißigkeit oder Dysphonie,
Dysphagie wurde verneint.
Er klagte über seine Probleme,
das könnte Gingivitis sein,
und chronische Szeneprobleme.
Er berichtete, dass die Beschwerden im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer geworden sind.
In der vegetativen Anamnese sind folgende Beschwerden bekannt.
Fieber, er habe es nicht gemessen.
Nachschweiß, seit einem Monat Gewichtverlust.
In einem Jahr 12 kg Gewicht abgenommen.
Er leidet seit zwei Jahren an Stuhlgang.
So wie Insomni, seit einem Monat Typform Einschlafstörung.
An Vorerkrankungen leidet er seit 20 Jahren an Diabetes mellitus.
Dagegen nimmt er mit Formen 100 mg Zwarfmaill täglich ein.
Insulin 6 Einheit täglich.
So wie leidet er seit 20 Jahren an arterieller Hypertonie.
Dagegen nimmt er Gamipril, die Dosis nicht erinnerlich ein.
Er hatte zweimal Herzinfarkt.
Dagegen nimmt er Beloxok 50 mg täglich ein.
Und Covaspin 100 mg täglich einnehmen.
Bei ihm wurde wegen des Herzinfarkts zweimal Angio-Katater durchgeführt.
Er habe zwei Ständen erhalten.
Er hatte eine Untervergleichung gegen Mischprodukte, die sich mit Abdominalgie äußern.
Er ist Raucher. Er rauchte seit 40 Jahren.
Seit 20 Jahren rauche er eine Schachtel Zigaretten täglich.
Dagegen raucht er zwei Schachtel Zigaretten täglich.
Seit ungefähr 30 Jahren trinkt er ein Glas Sekt täglich.
Drogenkonsum würde verleihen.
Er ist ledig, er lebt allein, er hat keine Kinder.
Er ist Frührentner wegen Erkrankungen.
Er ist vor zwei Jahren wegen Herzinfarkt.
In der Familienanamnese fand sich die Mutter gesund.
Der Vater ist vor zwei Jahren an Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Der Bruder ist mit 40 Jahren an Lungenkrebs verstorben.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Meine Verdachtstiagnose lautet auf Lippenkarzinom.
Dafür schiebe ich 5. Hände Ulcus oder Geschwür im Unterlips.
Er leidet an Gingivitis und 10 Probleme.
In der Familienvorgeschichte ist der Bruder an Lungenkrebs verstorben.
Er ist Raucher, er ist Kettenraucher.
Die Differenzialdiagnostik kommt oft durch Lesionen.
Denken Sie an Herpes Labialis bei diesen Patienten?
Die Differenzialdiagnose dauert nicht zwei Monate.
Ich habe es nicht gedacht.
Zur Diagnostik würde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Dabei achte ich auf Hassknoten als Vergrößerung.
Ich würde die Diagnostik durchführen.
Ich würde die Röntgen voranlassen, weil er Husten hat, um eine mögliche Pneumonie oder eine mögliche Metastasen auszuschließen.
Ich würde die Ultraschall des Hals durchschlagen, um eine mögliche Knoten- oder Vergrößerung der Schildgröße auszuschließen.
Um meine Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigen würde ich eine Gewebeprobe entnehmen.
Wenn möglich, sollte ich eine Extirpationell-Biopsie durchführen.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich ein HNO-Konzil anlassen, um die Therapie zu optimieren.
In diesem Fall sind die Therapie-Möglichkeiten eine Operation für eine chirurgische Entfernung und zu gehörigen Lempknoten.
Das war alles überrascht.
Welche Risikofaktoren kennen Sie bei einer Lippenkartinu?
Gingivitis, Cene-Probleme, Nikotin-Abusus, genetische Fernlagerung und chronische Erkrankungen wie Diabetes mellitus, arterielle Hypatonie.
Ist UV-Exposition ein Risikofaktor für eine Lippenkartinu?
Wir erwarten Platensukramus, Platenepithelial-Carsenum. Deswegen ist UV-Exposition ein Risikofaktor für eine Lippenkartinu.
Welche Berufe können Sie als Risikofaktoren nennen?
Bauarbeiter, Bauarbeiter, Bauarbeiter, Bauarbeiter in der Straße arbeiten.
Also Gärtner zum Beispiel oder Fischermann zum Beispiel.
Also Nikotinkonsum und Alkoholkonsum ist auch sehr wichtig. Sie haben es schon gesagt.
Welche Lokalisation erwarten Sie am meisten?
Am meisten erwarten wir Unterlippen.
Warum?
Platen-Adenokarsenum, Unterlippen, Platenepithelial-Carsenum erwarten wir.
Und UV betrifft...
Exposition, Sie können sagen.
Also ist mehr am Unterlippen.
Okay, also...
Welche...
Also wie würden Sie die Therapie planen bei diesem Patienten? Nochmal bitte.
Ich würde so schnell wie möglich ein HNO-Konstil veranlassen, um die Therapie zu optimieren.
Zuerst sollten wir Lymphknoten mit Invasion oder Lymphknotenwachtung beurteilen und eine mögliche Metastase darstellen.
Deswegen würde ich CT-Torax und CT-Hals durchschauen. Gegebenenfalls würde ich ein PET-CT durchschauen, um eine Metastase darzustellen.
Okay, also bei fortgeschrittenem Stadium sollte man eine Radiotherapie machen.
Ja, wenn es keine Invasion oder keine Metastase gibt,
sollte man eine operative Entfernung durchführen.
Okay, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine Hals-Sonographie durchführen. Können Sie bitte die Hals-Sonographie erklären?
Ja, Sonographie ist eine bildgebende Untersuchung mit der Hilfe von Ultraschall.
Wir können Weichgewebe beurteilen.
Das Gerät hat Schallkopf und ein Monitor. Schallkopf gibt einen Ultraschall und er nimmt die Antwort.
Wir können Halsgewebe oder Bauch in dieser Methode beurteilen.
Es ist eine schmerzfreie Methode. Vor der Untersuchung sollte der Patient oder die Patientin nicht vorbereiten.
Nach der Untersuchung kann der Patient oder die Patientin seinen gewohnten Alltag fortsetzen.
Es gibt keine Komplikation.
Okay, vielen Dank. Herr Kollege, bitte gehen Sie zum Infodesk und nehmen Sie Ihr Zertifikat. Gratulation.
Vielen Dank.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne den Patienten vorstellen. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Bitte schön.
Es handelt sich um Mario Leber. Er ist 62 Jahre alt, 1,77 Meter groß, 98 Kilogramm schwer.
Der Patient steht heute bei uns wegen zwei Monaten bestehenden Urkuss in der Oberlipe vor.
Der Patient ist zufolge die Beschwerden im Verlauf der Zeit immer größer und dicker geworden.
Er erwähnt, dass er beim Jucken eine Blutung und beim Scharfen Essen ein brennendes Gefühl bemerkt.
Der Patient ist deswegen nicht anderer Arzt gewesen. Er hat dagegen keine Medikamente eingenommen.
Der Patient berichtet über eine Gewichtabnahme von zwei Kilogramm innerhalb von einem Jahr.
Die Beschwerden gehen mit Pyrexie und Nachschweiß einher.
Die vegetative Anamnese hat folgendes ergeben. Belastung abhangiger Dispnö.
Tussis mit gelblichen Schleimen, Schupputum, Obstipation und Insomnie.
Die Anforderkrankungen nannte er seit 20 Jahren bestehende Diabetes mellitus.
Dagegen nimmt er mit Formen 1000 mg zweimal täglich und Insulin ab und ein.
Außerdem hat er seit 20 Jahren arterielle Hypertonik.
Dagegen nimmt er RamiPril Tablet, Kora Spin 100 mg, 100 mg ein.
Der Patient hat zwei Mal Myokardinfarktus.
Er wurde bei ihm ein Geo zweimal durchgeführt und der Patient wurde mit einem Stent behandelt.
Außerdem nimmt der Patient Benoxol 40 mg ein.
Der Patient hat Milchprodukte Allergie und Laptoseintoleranz.
Die äußern sich Bauchschmerzen, Abdominalschmerzen.
Der Patient ist Raucher.
Seit 20 Jahren hat er zwei Schachtel Zigaretten geraut.
Er trinkt ein Glas täglich und wird nicht in der Drogenkonsumung verneint.
Im Besuch auf die Familie Anamnese teilt er mit dem Vater, der vor zwei Jahren mit Myokardinfarktus verstorben ist.
Die Mutter ist gesund.
Der Bruder ist vor acht Jahren an Bronchelkarsenon verstorben.
Er ist Rentner, aber er ist früher als Angestellter gearbeitet.
Er hat eine Anzeige, die er in der Drogenkonsumung verwendet hat.
Er hat Stress, ist ledig und wohnt alleine.
Er hat keine Kinder.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf Lippenkarzinom aus.
Der Patient hat typische Symptome.
Der Patient hat chronische Lippenulkus.
Der Patient hat viele Risikofaktoren.
Der Patient ist Raucher und hat chronische Gingivitis und einiges Probleme.
Dafür ist diese Schiefforschung für die Mutter sehr wichtig.
Als die Differenziärdiagnose kommt, kommt auch die Herpetflexinfektion, Pilzinfektion und Verletzung in den Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich die Mutter in der Drogenkonsumung verabschieden.
Dann werde ich den Patienten körperliche Unterzucht durchführen.
Dabei werde ich die Lippe palpieren, ob es eine Anzeige gibt, die die Mutter nicht verabschiedet.
Außerdem werde ich den Patienten fast palpieren.
Dabei werde ich darauf achten, ob die Mutter nicht verabschiedet.
Dann werde ich die Mutter auf die Knochen oder die Schwellungen auf die Knochen schieben.
Dann werde ich darauf achten, ob es Knochen oder Schwellungen gibt.
Neben der körperlichen Unterzucht werden Labarunterzuchtungen sinnvoll, um eine unfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Dabei werde ich Blutbild, BSG, CRT, Elektrolyte, serologische Tests wie Herpes und Zyphilis bestimmen lassen.
Außerdem werde ich den Patienten eine Probe, GWB entnehmen für Labarunterzuchtungen.
Dann werde ich den Patienten eine Probe, GWB entnehmen für Labarunterzuchtungen.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Verwendung einverstanden sind, werde ich mit dem Geplanten und der Zuchten fortfahren.
Herr Kollege, würden Sie in diesem Fall eine EKG schreiben?
Ja, ich werde den Patienten eine EKG schreiben, weil der Patient eine belastungsabhängige Atemnot hat.
Um diese Probleme auszuschließen, werde ich den Patienten eine EKG schreiben.
Wie können Sie Herpes Simplex ausschließen?
Anamnestisch ist nicht typisch für Herpes-Infektionen.
Der Patient hat mir gesagt, dass die Beschwerden dauern.
Um diese Probleme auszuschließen, werde ich einen serologischen Test für Herpes Simplex im Immunglobin oder im Immunglobin G machen.
Welche Hautkrebs denken Sie in diesem Fall?
Ich denke, nicht basale Karsenoma. Ich denke, ich bin dermatologisch.
Nein, nicht welche Hautkrebs. Epidermoid Karsenoma. Ich denke.
Schommerkarsenoma.
Wie können wir ein Schommerkarsenoma diagnostizieren?
Um meine Verdachtstheor
Schommerkarsenoma kann Metastas machen, besonders Halsknoten und vielleicht Lungenmetastas.
Wie können wir ein Metastas diagnostizieren?
Um Metastase zu verteilen, werde ich Zintigraphie durchführen.
Wie?
Um die M-RT zu verbreiten.
Gibt es besondere Computerisatomographien für die Zintraphie?
Ja, ich weiß aber, ich habe jetzt vergessen.
Positioner-Emission-Tomographie.
Wie arbeitet Position-Emission-Tomographie?
Position-Emission-Tomographie ist eine Unterzugsmethode.
Aber ich habe es nicht jetzt erklärt.
Mit dieser Unterzugsmethode können wir die Zintraphie durchführen.
Okay.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall eine Halszontographie durchführen?
Halszontographie? Ja, es wäre ziemlich, eine Halszontographie durchführen,
möglichst Metastas auszuschließen.
Was erwarten Sie bei der Zontographie in der Halsz?
Ich erwarte eine Veränderung der Halsgefäße.
Also, wenn es eine Metastas in der Halsgefäße gibt,
dann würde ich die Halsgefäße durchführen.
Erwarten Sie in diesem Fall auch eine Festkontrolle in der Halsgefäße?
Ja, wenn ich eine Festkontrolle verpalme,
dann würde ich die Halsgefäße durchführen.
Okay. Ich habe alle Fragen gestellt.
Bitte gehen Sie in unser Info-Desk und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifizierung.
Danke schön.
Patienten aufgenommen. Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen, haben Sie gerade Zeit?
Ja, ich kann.
Ich berichte über den 62-jährigen Patienten, Herrn Mario Leber,
der 1,77 Meter groß ist und 98 Kilogramm wiegt.
Der Patient stellte sich heute bei uns,
seit zwei Monaten beschleunigt und langsam prognostiert,
Lesionen unter der Lippe 4.
Die Lesion hat eine Blutende Oberfläche und
die Lesion ist im Laufe der Zeit in der Lesion
sehr klein und groß geworden.
Außerdem klagte er über Fieber bis 38 Centigrad
und auch nächtliche Superhydrose.
Der Patient hat 12 Kilogramm im letzten Jahr abgenommen.
Die Frage nach Inapetans, Düstnö, Takikardi, Düstrhythm und die anderen wurden verneint.
Er klagte auch über Füße seit zwei Jahren mit gelblichem und schleimigem Auswurf.
Die Vorerkrankungen ergab Typ 2 Diabetes mellitus seit 20 Jahren,
arterial hypertoni seit 12 Jahren und der Patient hat zweimal Herzinfarkt.
Er wurde zweimal mit Stand behandelt.
Er nimmt regelmäßig 1000 Milligramm Morgens und Abends
und spritzt 6 Einheiten Insulin abends und Ramipril Morgens und Abends,
Horaspin 100 Milligramm Morgens, Beloxok 50 Milligramm Morgens.
Der Patient weiß die Dosierung von Ramipril nicht,
deswegen sollte die Dosierung geklärt werden.
Vorerkrankungen sind unaufwendig bis auf Stand behandelt.
Er hat Laktosintoleranz, die sich mit Abdominalschmerzen äußert.
Er ist vollständig geimpft und die Reiseanamnese wurde verneint.
Er raucht 60 Packung Jahre Zigaretten und trinkt halb Glas 6 Abends.
Drogenkonsum wurde vermeint.
In der Familienanamnese gab er das,
sein Vater an vor zwei Jahren Myokardial infarktus gestorben
und sein Bruder an vor zehn Jahren Bronchial carcinom gestorben.
Seine Mutter ist gesucht.
Er ist leidig, er ist frühen wegen chronischer Krankungen,
aber er hat als Büroangestellter gearbeitet. Er hat keine Kinder.
Die Anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf
Psychomagensel, Lippencarcinom,
differenzial diagnostisch kommen Herpes, Simplex
und Bazocellular Carcinom in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen,
würde ich die Empathien zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Ich achte, ich palpiere ganz heiß, ob es einen vergrößerten Lymphknoten
oder Lymphadenomegalie gibt.
Ich höre die Lungen ab, ob mögliche Lungencarcinome auszuschließen
oder Lungenbefunde zu finden.
Er hat starkes Rauchen, er ist starkes Rauchen.
Deswegen möchte ich auch Lungen abhören.
Ich werde ganz körperlich untersuchen, ob es einige Befunde gibt.
Ich würde den Patienten ambulant behandeln.
Die Allgemeinsuchten sind zurzeit gut, meine Meinung nach.
Ich würde gerne auch einen Ultraschall des Hals durchführen,
um mögliche Lymphknoten zu bestätigen.
Ich werde auch zwei Ebenen durchführen, um mögliche Lungenpathologie, Lungenkrebs auszuschließen.
Natürlich würde ich auch Blut abnehmen,
um die genaue Diagnose zu bestimmen.
Anschließend würde ich eine Gewebeprobe entnehmen, um die genaue Diagnose zu bestimmen.
Okay, in Therapie?
Die Therapie ist abhängig von der Diagnose.
Wenn es ein Skolomoff-Cell-Cartinom ist,
müssen wir und auch abhängig vom Stadium,
wenn es ein Örtliche-Cartinom ist, müssen alle oder ganz Lesionen entfernen.
Wenn es eine Methastase gibt, müssen wir Chemotherapie oder Radiotherapie planen.
Wenn es ein Basocelival-Cartinom ist,
ist es nur ein Örtliche-Cartinom,
deswegen ist nur eine Chirurgische Therapie sinnvoll.
Um eine mögliche Therapie zu planen,
würde ich auf eine plastische Chirurgische Konzilie antworten.
Welche Risikofaktoren kennen Sie für ein Lipinkartinom?
Oder hat der Patient?
Er ist ein sehr starker Raucher.
Er ist ein Risikofaktor.
Er hat in der Familienanamnese Belastung für Lungen-Cartinom.
Das hat eine Verbindung mit Lipen-Cartinom,
aber es gibt eine Familienbelastung über Carte-Cinom.
Welche Risikofaktoren kennen Sie für ein Lipinkartinom?
Ich habe keine genaue Information,
aber ich habe eine Nachdenkliche Schrift.
Hat der Patient eine chemische Kontakt?
Der Patient ist ein Angechter.
Ich habe keine Frage, aber während der Körperversuchung
kann ich fragen, ob es eine chemische Kontakt gibt.
Hat der Patient früher schon mal Haut oder Schlamm-Hautveränderungen?
Laut dem Patienten sind diese Lesionen erstmals aufgetreten.
Und bevor hat er keine Information über diese Lesionen gegeben?
War der Patient schon beim Zahnarzt oder andere Arzt deswegen?
Oder benutzt er einige Medikamente oder Lokaltherapie?
Nein, wir haben keine Information über Zahntherapie oder beim Zahnarzt.
Sie haben gesagt, dass der Allgemeinzustand gut ist.
Und der Ernährungszustand?
Er ist gut, aber er hat 12 Kilo abgenommen.
Das zeigt, dass wir eine Metastase denken können.
12 Kilo abgenommen zeigt uns eine Metastase.
Okay, gibt es auch eine Schrankung beim Essen, Trinken oder Sprayen?
Er hat keine Schürükbeschwerden, keine Inapetens, keine Ernährungsbeschwerden.
Nur hat er Laktosintoleranz. Das ist chronisch.
Wie würden Sie die Lesion beschreiben?
Das ist eine ulzerende und blutige Hautlesion.
Große, Lokalisation.
Große ist unterliegend.
Unterliegend, ulzerende, langsam, blutende.
Okay, Konsistenzrand, große Lokalisation.
Wir haben keine Informationen, aber normalerweise hat der Patient 2 x 1 cm.
Wie gränsen Sie einen Lipenkarsinn von einer Herpes- oder Physikfunktion ab?
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall eine Gewebeprobe machen und mit unterzuchten Pathologen genau diagnostizieren.
Okay, und denken Sie an eine Basarkarsin?
Das ist eine Basocelularkarsin.
Sie kann auch an der Unterlippe aufgetreten werden, besonders im Gesicht.
Deswegen muss ich die Basikarstin mit einer Biopsie genau diagnostizieren.
Okay, wir haben schon viel Zeit.
Okay, vielen Dank.